join me
explore the multiverse
and ask the question
what if
everybody knows how iron man became iron
man how cap became captain the fun twist
is that we go in different directions
and what does that look like and it's
like wait what
what if as a concept and as a comic book
is something that would always come up
in conversation it was almost like it
was marvel's twilight zone
for our show we're not borrowing
anything that was pre-done in the comic
we're riffing on the marvel movie
cinematic version of those characters
that's what's wonderful about this what
if concept
anything
can be explored
what if ultron won what if thor was
never banished what happens next
when brian and brad pitched the notion
of using norman rockwell as a basis for
the the style of the show i mean that's
my bread and butter i love that stuff
[Music]
it's pretty exciting when you see it all
come together that's some of the best
storytelling we've ever had
what if
gives us a whole new
idea of what the physical reality of the
universe is it is something that's going
to be explored in other ways moving
forward in our films
[Music]